de fibras vegetales a muebles son sus
productos que día a día la familia de
mirna ribera elabora su negocio podría
legalizarse después de que el gobierno
cubano aprobará una serie de leyes que
reconocen las micro pequeñas y medianas
empresas como actores económicos
más o menos como 25 personas
y cada cuánto vamos
y
después de 53 años la empresa privada
vuelve a abrirse camino en cuba el
miércoles el gobierno de miguel díaz
canel autorizó los primeros 35 negocios
privados desde que el líder de la
revolución cubana fidel castro
nacionalizar el sector en 1968
el ministerio de economía y
planificación informa al consejo de
ministros la aprobación de las 35
primeras mipymes en cuba' satisface que
la mayoría se dediquen a la producción
de alimentos la manufactura el reciclaje
y que estén en 11 de las 15 provincias
este camino recién empieza y no se
detendrá aunque la reforma podía
llevarse a cabo desde 2011 las
autoridades demoraron su ejecución hasta
ahora para muchos expertos es un primer
paso hacia una economía mixta que
también podría aumentar la producción en
el país pese al optimismo las empresas
deberán ceñirse a varias limitaciones
las actividades de importación y
exportación estarán intermediadas por el
gobierno y no se podrán crear empresas
en sectores reservados para el control
estatal como lo son las
telecomunicaciones el turismo y la salud